hey hey guys welcome back to the channel
and as you can tell by the screen right
now we're playing we happy few it's like
a psychological kind of survival game
from what I've heard played about a
couple minutes of the game so I would I
haven't really seen anything else about
this game yet as you can tell so let's
start a new game second win puts the
player in a dying state when their
health reaches zero yes permadeath when
permadeath is enabled your characters
gone forever die I don't trust myself
and this would that would be a very
short episode if I died whether to play
the character prologue before this
before starting up the game yeah sure
course perfect alright let's start
the only thing I really know about this
game is that you um it's something about
joy which is like a pill which reminds
me a [ __ ] ton of ecstasy and something
about how you're a downer I'm not
entirely sure just saying I saw the
gameplay it looked real nice and I
thought of it a perfect series
happy is the country with no past
oh so I guess I'm like a newspaper guy i
guess i don't remember this isn't how
newspapers are or maybe i'm not even
making newspapers that think I'm just
like approving them i assume i don't
know how this [ __ ] works to be honest
yeah no swimming in the river no
Hastings brothers wind scrap gathering
prize
when life for noise top up your joy
character sounds like he's having a
flashback of some sort should just take
my joy good night yeah that's wrong with
that uh hell yeah I'll take the joy
right happiness is a choice yeah
happiness is a choice snug is a problem
of drug
my what
oh my god did I just beat the game no
way there's no way the developers added
a option for me to beat the game without
even literally starting it no way that's
amazing that's [ __ ] beautiful all
right we're gonna skip this stuff I
swear to God if I have to watch all that
[ __ ] again aah and just take a sip of my
drink real quick
I still cannot believe they added that
as a choice that's [ __ ] awesome so
what I got from that is that this joy is
like a a what if how would I explain
this um like a happiness drug I guess
that makes you forget about things so
that you just keep living your life as
happy as possible which I mean it's not
bad but I think when it goes to this
extent it's a very big problem and now I
gotta watch the [ __ ] all over again of
course oh heavens no
oh here's my flashback
when life annoys top up your joy how the
hell did they make a pill that just for
it makes you forget about things and
just goes on living happiness that's
insane all right this time we're not
going to take it [ __ ] [ __ ]
what have you been up to no one's seen
you for hours Oh nose to the grindstone
you know then why haven't I heard a
single whoosh through the door since ten
o'clock did you forget we're having
Deirdre's birthday party we've got a
pinata oh right classy brilliant of
course I'll [ __ ] she found out course
not snug as a bug on a drug well come on
then finish up just have a few more
pages uh I know you're very busy then
don't take too long to finish oh my god
did you just see her tint do you see her
face when she took that what do you do I
no one yeah oh okay there we go profits
well anyways look off do you know that
good Christ office you've never done
this before in your life how does she
know well I expect you in the conference
room presently don't dawdle you don't
want to miss the pinata uh oh I'm
supposed to be coming back today I made
a welcome back code I don't exactly know
if this if that means anything if I
accept or sensor these I don't know what
half of it means to be honest we'll just
accept this one all right stand up good
[ __ ] out here
oh okay so my name is Arthur Hastings
and I guess going to that newspaper
Percy was my brother in a threesome I
assume something bad happen you're
offered the party aren't you whatever
happened to you prudence you know coming
back oh you brute why did you go uh-huh
Oh what the hell they just he just
stabbed a person with the [ __ ]
syringe with full of joy what hi anyone
else notice that that guy had yellow
yellow rain boots on we seem to be a big
dog and I'll work now that you mention
it oh my god this business I come into
work you guys having no this is [ __ ]
pathetic I never noticed that we should
fix the hell panting a bit lucky oh nice
there you are you nearly missed the
pinata it's the most adorable Spanish
custom Uncle Jack did a whole show
that's it you smash it until all the
candy comes out so I guess this is a
custom where everyone wears masks what
the [ __ ] are you hitting it with I got
you Oh what the [ __ ] why was it bleeding
what do you eat oh Jesus Christ I just
[ __ ] Club to rat you take one of mine
but no no I'm good boss
he's a down she's faint not [ __ ] it
we're going where do we go I all right
let's get the [ __ ] out here to list of
it don't even give a [ __ ] about your
raise nope run I'll nice recovery there
go go go open the door of course the
[ __ ] dead end and across the doors
locked I'll hit it with it oh good block
learn the [ __ ] swing Arthur great now
we're dead
believe i'm still alive more or less oh
yeah you just got clogged in the head
with a crime what's going on today the
conch I'm back I've got to get out of
here oh that's great the circus is
coming filtered water okay don't was
broken oh [ __ ] we could fly me it's mrs.
Stokes I'll she hung herself I'll can't
be so proud okay and it looks like she's
gone off her rocker perfect so I take it
from the top left is that I'm low on
health kind of not kind I shouldn't save
low it's about seventy percent I mean I
did get clogged in the [ __ ] head with
a baton so Alex place doesn't look too
bad looks pretty uh yeah okay well
that'll be the end of the video guys I'm
probably going to go record the next
episode immediately after our end this
one but oh but always guys like the
video if you enjoyed comment your
opinion and subscribe if you're new guys
and peace